[Musica]
buonasera come ha detto alessandro sono
andrea maurizio gilardoni genitore e
formatore e imprenditore della nuova era
come avete notato la prima definizione è
genitore perché in questa fase della mia
vita ho due figlie una di 11 ore di 12
anni kate e karin è il mio compito credo
che sia quello come quello di tutti i
genitori
credo che sia quello di portarle a poter
vivere una vita che desiderano una vita
diciamo straordinaria siete d'accordo
no no il solito ai miei corsi funziona
così che al 3 si dice sbam
proviamo 123 ci piace ci piace
quindi quando con i miei quando con mia
moglie lucia abbiamo deciso di avere dei
bambini abbiamo anche deciso che avremmo
dovuto spianargli il quanto più
possibile la strada il che non vuol dire
farle fargli trovare la pappa pronta ma
quantomeno dagli l'esempio di quello che
potevano po avrebbero potuto costruirsi
nella loro vita è una delle cose più
importanti una delle cose che facciamo
di più nella vita tutti noi è quella di
lavorare quella di lavorare tante tanti
anni della nostra vita quindi credo che
pensare a come instradarli al mondo del
lavoro anche prima che loro arrivassero
a quel punto fosse una cosa importante e
quindi ci siamo fatti questa questa
domanda che lavoro dovrebbero scegliere
le mie figlie perché comunque ovviamente
la scelta rimarrà sempre e comunque a
loro ma come possiamo influenzare le
nostre bambine in modo tale che loro
possano vivere una vita libera che credo
sia la cosa che tutti a cui tutti
dovremmo tendere e quindi ci siamo un po
guardato in giro e questi numeri erano
quelli che io avevo vissuto fino dai 14
più o meno ai 25 30 anni cioè lavorare 8
10 a volte anche 12 ore al giorno sei
giorni su sette a volte da alcuni
periodi anche sette giorni su sette
350 giorni all'anno e per 15 giorni di
vacanza
ansa ci siamo chiesti questo è quello
che le scuole quello che la ditta quello
che tutti ci dicono lavora tanto lavora
di più e vedrai che otterrai di più
giusto e quello che le persone
solitamente dicono e quindi abbiamo
detto come possiamo fargli trovare la
loro strada ma scollegando questo
fattore cioè scollegando da quello che
secondo me che porterebbe a vivere una
vita di rinuncia una vita dove molto
probabilmente non farebbero esattamente
quello che vorrebbero e allora ci siamo
un po ingegnati una delle cose come
avete sentito la seconda cosa che con la
quale mi piace definirmi che la mia
passione quella della formazione essere
un formatore ho incominciato a studiare
non tanto per me ma quanto per riuscire
a dare un significato e un segno una
strada un percorso alle mie figlie e
quindi nel mio nel mio studio nella mia
ricerca ho incontrato anche questa
metafora che vorrei raccontarvi negli
stati uniti ieri più che la metafora è
una storia abbastanza vera negli stati
uniti hanno fatto un esperimento in
esperimenti hanno preso delle pubblici
che in natura le pulci non so se lo
sapevate ma saltano fino a due metri che
cosa hanno fatto hanno preso queste
pulci e le hanno messe un gruppo di
queste pulci in un vaso di vetro
trasparente alto un metro
le pulci all'inizio saltavano e ti
chiamano la testa diciamo contro il
soffitto di questo vaso di vetro ed
hanno lasciate per qualche giorno
all'interno di questo ambiente
a un certo punto hanno tolto questo vaso
di vetro e si sono resi conto che tutte
queste pulci non saltavano più sopra i
novanti i 99 cm perché non saltavano più
perché quando sentivano dolore si erano
fermate e avevano imparato a saltare
solo fino a 99 cm la cosa straordinaria
però ed è per questo che questa storia
mi ha colpito e ve la voglio raccontare
oggi è che queste pulci
una volta che hanno avuto dei figli
hanno comunicato hanno trasmesso ai loro
figli che non si poteva saltare fino a 2
metri e anche tutti i figli ei figli dei
figli di queste pubblici hanno scoperto
che non saltavano più sopra i due metri
sopra il metro e questa sarà per me è
molto significativa perché questo voleva
dire che avrei dovuto dare l'esempio
gli avrei dovuto togliermi tutte quelle
convinzioni o avere comunque o mettere
comunque in discussione tutte quelle
cose che le persone là fuori credono
essere vere e così con mia moglie
abbiamo deciso di intraprendere la
nostra carriera nel mondo
dell'immobiliare nel mondo della
formazione nel mondo della vita libera e
abbiamo capito che scambiare il proprio
tempo per il denaro non è mai la cosa
giusta cioè il prezzo di ogni cosa se tu
lavori per il denaro diventa troppo
costosa perché non la pagheresti più con
i tuoi soldi o meglio non la paghi più
con i tuoi soldi ma la stai pagando con
il tempo che ha impiegato per guadagnare
quel denaro e quindi le mie figlie
volevo trasmettere questo concetto cioè
sicuramente ci sarà un periodo dove
dovrai andare a lavorare scambiando il
tuo tempo per il denaro questo è normale
sicuramente dovrai studiare e impiegare
il tuo tempo per imparare e apprendere
delle competenze e diventare una persona
più capace o una persona migliore ma di
sicuro a lungo termine scambiare il
proprio tempo per il denaro non è la
cosa giusta però qual è la cosa giusta
da fare perché se non vado a lavorare se
non scambio il mio tempo per il denaro
qual era la cosa giusta da fare
quale era la cosa giusta da insegnare a
due creature che avevamo messo al mondo
per questo che credo che il denaro e il
lavoro siano controversi perché le
persone che vanno a lavorare in realtà
vanno a lavorare per il denaro
siete tutti d'accordo le persone vanno a
lavorare per il denaro o meglio vanno a
lavorare perché hanno bisogno del denaro
e molti di loro o meglio pochi di loro
vanno a lavorare per passione nella mia
ricerca da formatore mi sono reso conto
che c'erano questi due numeri importanti
che sono accaduti nel 2018 proprio pa in
italia sono due numeri molto
significativi che confermano il fatto
che i risultati che otteniamo vengono
dati non tanto dal lavoro che facciamo
ma da quello che crediamo dalle
convinzioni che abbiamo infatti se
andate a ricercare sul sole 24 ore
credit suisse ha fatto una ricerca in
tutta europa e non solo e ha scoperto
che nel 2018
questo numero mi ha impressionato quando
me l'hanno detto o meglio quando sono
andato a leggere questa ricerca di
credit suisse nel 2018 in italia in
italia 200 mila persone sono diventate
milionarie non 2000 non 20 mila 200 mila
persone nel 2018 sono diventate
milionarie in italia e allo stesso tempo
nello stesso paese con la stessa
politica con le stesse tasse con lo
stesso clima con le stesse condizioni
245 mila persone sempre in italia hanno
perso la casa
questo dato mi ha confermato che non è
l'ambiente in cui vivi che non è il
posto in cui sei nato che non è quello
che ti circonda fa la differenza ma come
reagisce al mondo che ti circonda e come
ti comporti e quello che credi e ho
capito che per guadagnare non bisogna
avere un lavoro
questo è quello che vuole essere il mio
messaggio per le mie bambine e anche per
voi ma bisogna avere una strategia
bisogna avere delle regole bisogna
programmarsi purtroppo o per fortuna in
questa economia il denaro serve per
curarsi per mangiare per vivere per
viaggiare per creare una famiglia per
sostenere per avere dei propri hobby per
sostenere le proprie persone che a cui
teniamo alle persone care vicino a noi
però lavorare non significa scambiare il
proprio tempo per il denaro e adesso vi
spiego perché ci sono alcune regole la
prima regola è quella che secondo me il
denaro non siamo noi a dover lavorare
per il denaro ma è il denaro che deve
lavorare per noi
è una cosa a cui dobbiamo tendere tutti
non andare a lavorare per il denaro ma
mandare il denaro a lavorare per noi che
non è la prima fase
ovviamente come le mie figlie non è la
prima fase della loro vita è qualcosa a
cui dovranno tendere è la seconda regola
è che non importa da dove partì abbiamo
visto che nella stessa economia nel 2018
non 20 o 30 50 anni fa ci sono state 22
risultati opposti molto importanti e
quel risultato che vi ho raccontato fa
parte di migliaia di famiglie in italia
centinaia di migliaia
quindi non importa dove partì questo è
quello che volevo spiegare quello che
vorrà spiegare le mie figlie ma
insegniamo a loro a costruirsi la
possibilità di scegliere del proprio
destino del proprio tempo come lo
facciamo lo facciamo con quattro regole
la prima regola è che non devi avere
pregiudizi tutte le mattine dico le mie
bambine
prima di andare a scuola andato in bagno
e prendete il filo interdentale e
togliete tutte le cose negative che
pensate o che potrebbero influenzare un
filo interdentale immaginario quello che
serve per avere per costruirsi una
mentalità vincente
la seconda cosa che insegna le mie
figlie vai a studiare
vai a scuola quando sceglierà il tuo
percorso di studi non sceglierlo per
opportunità sceglierli sceglilo per
passione perché non deve per forza
essere quello il lavoro che ti farà
vivere impara le regole del denaro e
impara a costruirti nel tempo delle
entrate scollegate dal tuo tempo io e
mia moglie lucia facciamo questa cosa
tutti i giorni con gli immobili e stiamo
cercando di trasformi trasferire questa
passione non tanto delle case ma questa
capacità di generare denaro aiutando le
persone è una cosa che secondo me è
molto importante e riusciamo a farla con
le case e la quarta cosa che dico ai
miei figli e sempre è che le quali
auguro questa cosa è che alla fine tutti
dobbiamo diventare dobbiamo diventare
dobbiamo essere capaci di diventare
degli investitori cioè di mandare i
nostri soldi a lavorare il nostro posto
è un percorso a step la prima cosa è
costruire la nostra mentalità vincente
la seconda
per trovare un lavoro che ci appassioni
così non lavoreranno neanche un giorno
della loro vita
la terza cosa è quella di imparare le
regole del denaro in modo tale che anche
loro possano costruirsi la loro
indipendenza economica e quindi non
lavorare più neanche un secondo per il
denaro ma per creare valore al mercato e
alla fine l'unica cosa realmente
sostenibile è quella di mandare il
proprio denaro a lavorare al nostro
posto e sapete perché perché siamo nel
2019 e si dice che oggi la media della
nostra vita e circa intorno agli 87 anni
se prendiamo quattro persone due veri
due donne addirittura si sale a 97 anni
c'è uno di quelle persone dice fine 97
anni io credo che le mie figlie che
arriveranno
credo che le mie figlie arriveranno a
superare probabilmente i 100 anni di età
perché la medicina sono sicuro che farà
passi da gigante nei prossimi anni
e se non insegniamo a loro adesso queste
regole cioè le regole di dover di non
dover lavorare per il denaro ma di
mandare il denaro lavorare al nostro
posto
rischiano di vivere una vita che non sia
degna di essere vissuta
quindi sono piccole strategie che volevo
passare in questa giornata meravigliosa
che penso possano fare molto la
differenza non solo nella vita delle mie
figlie ma anche nella vostra vita
grazie
[Musica]